with two expansions in the season pass
under its belt destiny is now taking aim
at its big expansion the taken king and
here to talk about it on stage with me
is David dig aka DJ from Bungie
community manager extraordinaire David
welcome to the stage thanks good to be
here glad to have you here to tell us
some destiny I see you are rocking the
merchandise here yep nice taken King
t-shirt taking k just you're just
throwing am at us over in our booth
thrown to my people in line so got to
represent the new adventure what about
the people online they gonna get a shot
at those or is that an e3 exclusion III
exclusive all right they'll just have to
admire from afar exactly but taken King
uh folks were admiring that during the
sony press conference and seeing that
Oryx getting a little uh little mad he's
a he's irate he's like more than a
little furious yeah well I mean you
killed his son anybody who you know took
crotas own sword you know and sank it
into his face in the crotas end' raid
has earned a new enemy fathers have a
way about that things exactly exactly so
Oryx is the taken King he's the new
villain that you're going to confront in
destiny the taken King on sep tember
15th and he's bringing with him his dark
army they are the taken so they're the
new enemy that you're going to fight in
destiny some of the combatants that you
may have you know known and loved or
hated or vanquished in battle he's
ripped them from our dimension he's
twisted them with the darkness mutated
them into a horrible new infantry and
he's dispatching them into our solar
system to exact his revenge horrible new
infantry horrible that sounds great so
that's where the guardians of the last
safe city will find themselves this fall
well this horrible new infantry I think
we're gonna I'd love to sort of pick
your brain about what kind of new
effects they're bringing into the
battlefield do they have any new tricks
up their sleeves lilium and they're all
your characters it's an all new
combatant race so they have their own
ways to fight they have their own ways
to counter your attack I think it's
really going to change up the combat
sandbox specifically for the end of the
PvE encounters in the game and of course
in to give the Guardians what they need
to rise to the occasion for that fight
we are giving every single Guardian in
the game a brand new subclass
I can embrace and master so be you a
hunter a Titan or a warlock you're going
to grasp that third type of elemental
energy in our game that you've never
wielded before and now we need to go
through these subclasses and talk about
them a little bit yeah let's start with
my favorite and what I believe to be the
superior a guardian hunter all right
yeah we can start their bike to start
with a hunter I don't agree but that's
what makes the community such an
interesting place on everyone has
opinions some of them are better than
others so as a hunter you're used to
being very aggressive you're all about
the blade or the gun you charge in you
know you confront you know the enemies
you know hand-to-hand combat yep it's
all about going straight for the kill
this is about you being more of a
support player now so you're gonna grasp
that void energy I'm gonna have your
void bow okay your your night stalker is
going to have the shadow shot so you
draw that void bow back and it's going
to bind groups of teammates together
groups of teammates together so the
opposing team if they're clustered
together I mean that's when you want to
use your super right okay yeah there's
many many targets that you can use it on
so if you can take that bow and shoot it
at a group of people it'll bind them
together it'll trap them in essence so
you and your team can then move in for
the kill now when you say bind do you
mean sort of routes them to the ground
or does it draw them together in like a
big katamari ball for you to wraps them
where they are it creates beams of
energy connecting them together okay
everybody will just sort of look at each
other me like this is it is everyone
else operator on you ate a good run but
this is it prepare to respawn boys there
we see it in action right here these are
the binds of the yep there you go so
that's that's the shadow shot Dave
Samuels one of our effects artist sees
you know just as animated as the
characters are you gotta visualize the
effect somehow gestures AthLEAN powerful
way one of the great thing about working
at bungee is we're fans of our own game
so now we've got the the arc warlock the
Warlock is more aggressive than ever
he'll rush into battle he can stand
toe-to-toe with any guardian in the
sandbox right now any enemy and just
call down the storm in a trance and send
it right through his fingertips I do you
guys call this was the internal code
name for this the Palpatine no but
everyone at e3 saying Palpatine style
right you happen emalia if you must if
you must I mean he
sort of the iconic lightning bolts from
the fingertips zoom deliver guys so
check this out now we're looking at the
the solar Titan got the Sun breaker and
his hammer of Sol it's a great melee
weapon but you can also throw it from
afar and you can rain fiery incendiary
death down on fortified positions there
you go this Dave again so the throne in
then just sort of regenerating another
one ready then you get a whole bunch
you're just throwing hammers all day and
it lets the titan for the first time you
know have a ranged attack you don't have
to go in and charge in for hand-to-hand
combat you don't have to expose yourself
in the kill zone you can sort of hang
back and you can play as a support
figure and it's also an attack that uh
sort of lasts over time you know that
the other to tighten abilities are kind
of you pop it it's done yep this one is
more of a blade dance kind of thing you
can get a good run going yeah absolutely
and it's you know it's defensive in
nature you know the Titans sort of had
that bipolar element you know where your
are there you know gummy with the fists
of havoc charging in laying waste
everything in your immediate
surroundings or you got the defender
bubble that you've you know throw up you
know you guys got all the gestures down
yeah you don't become legend man you
know you gotta got to inhabit your
guardian yeah excellent all right so
that so the three subclasses are coming
folks are obliging obviously going to
have to work through that experience
Jamie sort of level them up and find out
the ways that they can be customized
within each other sort of skew it
towards one type of play style or
another but in addition to subclass I
mean the subclasses of course powerful
not only in PvP which we saw demo there
yeah but also in pv sorry where we
seeing PvP you looked at PBE that's what
I what also powerful in PvP that is
exactly the transition I was trying to
make the crucible competitive
multiplayer yes so let's talk about
crucible and how these powers are
balanced at sort of what new crucible
stuff you guys are bringing for the
taken guess so we're we have two booths
here at e3 we're back over there in the
PlayStation booth where we have mayhem
clash it's a team deathmatch variant but
we've taken the space magic we cranked
it all the way up to 11 your super meter
recharges faster than ever so it's super
abilities super attacks on top of super
abilities grenades melees like all the
cool things that make destiny fun and
explosive are magnified and amplify
wow yeah that sounds crazy chaos yeah
that does sound chaotic is that was that
a good sort of testing ground for you
guys in terms of the new subclass supers
like all right let's just let's just
blow it out but these things toe-to-toe
if they're just happening all the time
sure that's the great thing about having
a game and development as you can do
whatever you want with it you can see
what's fun here at e3 it's also been a
great way to introduce new players to
the super abilities because if you're
going to stand in line for hours at a
time and wait for your chance to get in
there and under you know experience
these new super abilities if they only
popped up once or twice during a match
you leave wanting more we're just we're
going to give you everything you want in
terms of your new Guardian you're going
to be able to you know use that void bow
you're going to be able to use the storm
trance again and again and again have a
lot of fun with it over in the
activision booth we're actually
introducing a new objective mode so you
know there's a neutral objective two
teams have bases on opposing sides of
the map there's a spark that's the
common explosive element you go in you
capture the spark you bring it to the
enemy base you use that to clear the
enemy team in to score points okay so
it's sort of a like a bomb delivery kind
of thing exactly and is it once you make
the delivery you're getting points for
the delivery and then it is it a sort of
area blast or something that can
actually kill the enemy team that's
nearby yeah it ends the round oh it
straight up and around score points you
know destroys the enemy team respawns in
the center and then you go back for it
all over again okay how many rounds are
you guys sorry I mean that the match has
a timer on it that ends the round where
you're going in and capturing the spark
then it respawns oh thank you gotta run
backs not like trials of Osiris yeah
it's a live-fire exercise the action
never stops but yeah anybody who's
defending that base they're going now
let's talk about act so spark carrying I
mean you know is this character carrying
the spark that we're seeing yep so
that's that's the runner yeah and the
idea is that you're going to go to the
opposing base they can kill you of
course and then the runner is stopped if
you do get there though if you do
deliver the spark into the enemy's rift
a boom boom and the animation is
something that we're having a lot of fun
with you know sort of amping those hero
moments where you get to you literally
get to slam dunk that spark you know
kind of an end zone celebration actually
even do it in full reverse you know and
do a backflip earn some style points for
your team a backflip yep yeah ah that
sounds wonderful I am really looking
forward to doing that now but you can't
you can't turn invisible with a spark
it's a it's kind of a you're gonna have
a target painted right on your back
absolutely so these guys are defending
their uh these guys are defending their
base right here uh-huh now then now
they've been bound by the shore shot
right at Oh shot right so it's not just
what it's restricting movement you're
sort of yeah you can move very slowly to
escape it but yeah it puts you put you
in a damp but it's also okay visual
obstruction I mean that whole screen was
lit up with just like bright purple
effects not making it really hard to get
a bead on your enemy yeah and that's
important we like to give players
feedback so that they're never confused
like why couldn't I move why did I guy
it's like you're in Kate encased in that
void energy so you have some
understanding of what's going on you
know that there's a void hunter
somewhere on the battlefield and that
guy knows what he's doing and you just
got tagged don't bunch up guys don't
bunch up the night long he's on his game
guys that's it's gonna be really
interesting to see what kind of
strategies emerge with the new subclass
abilities I so this is two new crucible
modes to new Cruiser in common with the
taken King up we're we have four new
maps here at e3 and that's just a
fraction of what will ship in the taken
King on September 15th now let's talk a
little bit about the size of the PvE
sort of strikes the story missions yeah
what kind of in terms of the story that
comes with the taken king is it
comparable in sort of size and mission
length to the dark below or house of
wolves much much larger than that this
is a major expansion that's how we're
referring to it ok so it's an offering
deserving of kicking off the second year
of destiny so last September the Destiny
adventure began community rushed into
that brave new world they made it
there's you know the new hobby began now
we're kicking off the second year of
gameplay and adventures shared moments
and the taken king is how we kick off
that second year so there's a full
campaign there's a full endgame suite of
activities for you to share with your
friends new crew
moans new supers new enemies when you
say full are you talking like
comparative to the original default is
closer to the destiny story that is to
any of the expansions that we've
released so Eric or sending you back out
into that world there's a new
destination for you to explore okay we
are opening up a new node on your
director where you're going to go and
conquer and explore the dread-nots which
is oryx's spacefaring fortress full of
loot and rituals and all sorts of
interesting events for you to share with
your friends a big old nasty spaceship
big old nasty spaceship full of bad guys
and awesome stuff for you to claim for
yourself things that will make your
guardian more powerful in some exciting
new way sounds great now before we wrap
let's just give a quick shout-out to
what kind of you guys our packaging some
new additions of destiny as well release
this fall yeah can you run those down
for us yeah well the taken king is going
to be a great offering for existing
players of destiny if you've been a
guardian with us since day one if you've
experienced everything that destiny has
to offer you know if you played the dark
below you played the house of wolves you
can jump right into the taken king with
a forty dollar upgrade okay and that
gets you everything that the game has to
offer all the new supers the new
destination the new modes the full raid
that we're you know creating back in the
studio the raid I can't believe we
didn't get time to talk about the ring
I'm not allowed to talk about the raid
you know I didn't put over my own
personal injury I'm not gonna split
there's a ray there's a raid alright
it'll be the most challenging element if
you don't know what a destiny rate is if
you've never played destiny the taken
king is a great entry point you know for
sixty dollars you can jump in you're
going to get destiny you're going to get
the two expansions you're going to get
the taken king you can begin your
adventure you can start with eyes up
guardian and go on your path and
there'll be some interesting ways for
you to catch up to your friends because
that's what it's all about and that is
that release is September 15th September
the 15th deej thank you so much talking
destiny the taken King here at e3 2015
alright folks will be back with another
demo here on the game spot stage at e3
I'm looking over there it's rise of the
Tomb Raider oh it's going to be good be
right back